décidé à madame le pen voit la future
fête aujourd'hui on a fait venir
quelqu'un de spécial
angéline longtemps chaput à 105 ans elle
suit encore tous les matchs du canadien
de montréal à la radio mais si le temps
a eu raison de sa vue sa mémoire est
encore excellente
madame longtemps chaput fait partie d'un
groupe où l'on retrouve de plus en plus
d'individus
les centenaires en l'espace d'un siècle
on a assisté à une véritable explosion
du nombre de centenaires
donc ils étaient environ une dizaine en
1920 au québec
et puis aujourd'hui on en dénombre à peu
près 1500 mais ceux qui comme elles
franchissent la barre des 100 ans sont
encore l'exception aujourd'hui à
l'intérieur de la classe des centenaires
on distingue ceux qui atteignent 150 nos
semis super centenaires et ceux qui
atteignent 110 ans les super centenaires
en fait seulement 60% des centenaires
atteignent l'âge de 101 ans tout juste 6
% se rendent à 105 ans et à peine un
centenaire sur 1000 devient un super
centenaires comme un hyper vient-il
l'hérédité certainement un facteur
important
elle est la dernière d'une famille de
dix enfants et la mère l'a précédée de
tel avant dernière de la famille ma mère
un avantage en deux ans et elle a 100
chèques ans qui était une donne des
gènes intéressants mais l'hérédité ce
n'est pas tout disent les spécialistes
en réalité les études montrent que ce
serait au maximum au plus 25 % la
longévité qui sera attribuable aux
facteurs héréditaires la balance c'est
sur les l'environnement les facteurs
comportementaux les habitudes de vie le
principal intéressé quant à elle parle
de sa vie calme de sa bonne santé et de
sa passion pour le bridge mais j'aime
beaucoup jouer aux cartes
et puis les femmes qui jouent au
baseball des mets moi ici non magon
radio-canada saint basile le grand